maintenant il faut qu'on arrive à
fédérer toute la gauche
ça devrait pas être trop trop difficile
puisqu'on a finalement gérer la région
pendant longtemps ensemble et donc on va
se retrouver pour éviter qu'elles ne
tombent à droite ou pire à l'extrême
droite lui donc je suis assez optimiste
sur le rassemblement de la gauche et
c'est ça qui fera la victoire parce que
moi aussi j'ai un ennemi en politique
c'est le front national
sinon j'ai des adversaires à droite
beaucoup mais j'ai un ennemi c'est le
front national et je pense que c'est
aussi le message qui peut peut-être
faire sortir un certain nombre
d'abstentionnistes de chez eux parce que
je crois que de voir le front national
en tête d'entendre régions en france
c'est quand même un coup de semonce pour
beaucoup de républicains au sens large